And I'm super excited to be here today to be with Danielle teller who is an
author and a dear friend and I'm going to share just a little bit about her.
She grew up in Canada where she was a bookworm and dreamed of being a writer,
but she chickened out and went to medical school instead and attended Queens
University as well as getting her medical training at Mcgill Brown and Yo.
She's held faculty positions at the University of Pittsburg and Harvard where
she investigated the origins of chronic lung disease and taught in the medical
intensive care unit.
Then in 2013 she quit her job to pursue that childhood dream of writing.
She Co wrote sacred cows the truth of divorce and marriage with her husband,
our own beloved astro teller.
She has also been a regular writer for courts where with width as well as data.
She writes about controversial,
yet accurate,
unseen truths hiding behind many of our long held beliefs and some of my
favorite column titles include the idiotic argument Americans use in almost
every political debate.
Let mom down from the pedestal in praise of the messy,
imperfect,
authentic mother,
which was a mother's Day writing.
Of course,
nearly all our medical research is wrong.
Okay.
How American parenting is killing the American marriage.
We're super excited to have Danielle here today and we'll be discussing her book
called all the other actors before we start discussing with her.
She's going to do a little reading for us.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
be here.
And I'm super impressed that people are taking time out of their busy work days
to be Harem very touched.
So thank you.
Um,
so I'm going to read the prologue from the book,
which I think really sets up
with the book is about and gives you a flavor of the style of writing.
Um,
and then I'll in a couple of sentences,
just describe the arc of the book and then we'll have a chat.
Yeah.
Um,
hopefully all of us,
we'll have a chat
prologue.
The royal courts.
Okay.
Suppers at the royal court to become entirely too oppressive.
It isn't just that they're interminable or that we must adhere to the newest
fashions,
the face powder or I hear tortured into great bejeweled Ram's horns,
the silks with sleep so tight that it's impossible to raise one spoon to one's
carefully tinctured lips.
No.
The worst is the gossip,
the sinister buzz of wasps ready to,
they're poisonous stingers into whatever tender flesh lies exposed.
This evening,
I was ordered to sit next to the Earl in Briston,
a pompous halfwit who has rarely been to court.
He presides over some God forsaken swamp and the north and he seems to believe
that his family's long history of loyalty to the crown gives him the right to a
pine on the behaviors of the royal family.
My Lady,
he said plucking at cuffs so voluminous that they draped into his suit.
I understand that you are noble daughters are not yet wed.
No.
My Lord,
I answered as briefly as courtesy would allow and yet I've heard that they once
vied for the attention of Prince Henry himself,
the Earl Dad's has crimson.
Let's daintily that they tried to alienate his affection from princess of
filter.
You seem amused.
My Lord,
he could not mistaken the coldness in my response.
I fear that much of what you have heard is not true.
Well,
it is an incredible tale.
He smiled broadly,
the beautiful downtrodden maiden who ascends to the royal palace,
the Jealous Sisters,
the glass slipper that would not fit my Lord.
I cannot credit such a tail.
Come at eight you know that the whole kingdom is enthralled by our radiant and
benevolent princess.
I've heard a great deal about you and your daughters.
He looked at me knowingly.
Compelling fiction often obscures the humble truth.
Do hope that you will.
Tell me about the slipper.
He said,
ignoring my reluctance.
He broke a piece of bread,
leaving a trail of crumbs across the table.
My wife is frantic to know the particulars.
They say that the prince that every made try the shoe,
even your daughters,
he laughed.
It is droll to imagine them receiving attention from a prince.
His drug was eloquent.
They are ugly and it filled is beautiful.
The Earl frowned and pursed his lips.
It's Genteel to imply nasty insults,
not to speak them directly.
My Lord.
I may have heard some of the rumors too,
which you allude to my mind.
The stories insinuate a plague of blindness.
Prince Henry would have to be blind not to recognize the object of his
admiration or to distinguish an ugly girl from one of unsurpassed beauty.
My daughters,
we need to be blind to the reflections and the mirrors and on the faces of those
who behold them.
My voice rose,
so I paused and began again.
Blandly.
They would also need to be blind to the truth that men persuade themselves that
beautiful women possess virtue and good character,
whereas no amount of virtue can make an ugly woman.
Beautiful.
My lady Princess,
a filter.
There's a dazzling star who shines in the royal for a moment where she belongs.
He did not attempt to conceal his disdain that she invites you and your
daughters to dine.
Here at the palace is a testament to her compassion,
forgiveness,
and generosity.
Indeed my Lord,
I remembered.
Okay,
indeed.
That is so,
yeah.
I'm only of interest to the Earl of Bryston and his ilk because of my
stepdaughter princess of Hilda is the most celebrated women in the kingdom,
perhaps in all of history.
Commoners line the streets for endless hours,
even in dark and sleep,
hoping to glimpse her face through the window of her gilded carriage.
When the princess has a gang cut in a new way or adopts a different hairstyle,
every female creature in the city imitates or appearance.
Last Autumn,
she wore a choker of pearls to church on Michaelness and the next day,
every noble woman's throat was wound snuggly with pearls or other jewels.
By Christmas tied,
even the peasant girls wear chokers of beads or ribbon.
Whatever material they could find to replicate the fashion princess of filled.
His popularity derives in large part from her astonishing beauty.
There's something else about her nature that attracts the masses,
her habitual mutinous and the gentle hesitancy of those rare words that do fall
from her lips make her seem bashful,
as does her manner of ducking her head and looking up through sweeping lashes.
Apart from her collection of bubbles and Kendall,
the favorite dogs.
She appears to have no passions or vices.
And when she attends royal functions,
her gaze drifts to invisible spectacles that only she can apprehend.
Her elusive character is a blank parchment upon which any story may be written.
And every girl who dreams of becoming a princess can imagine herself in Princess
of fill this heinously tiny shoes.
I know more of the princesses history than anyone else alive.
And the true tale is not as fantastical as the ones sung by troubadours.
No,
but he's interested in the story of a flesh and blood nobleman.
His daughter,
when who wet her bed,
complained a boredom thought with her kin and turned up her nose at Winter
Greens,
just like any mortal child.
And what do I have any desire to diminish the adulation for the princess,
which makes both the admiring and the admired.
So content,
I do not set out to write the princesses history,
but my own,
the only tale I have the authority to tell my quill may resurrect ghosts to keep
me company during the long days at the castle.
And if it cannot,
at least my mind will be occupied.
And my hands busy as for fables about good and evil and songs about glass
slippers,
I shall leave those to the minstrels.
They can invent their own tales.
That's Cinderella.
So that's the prologue,
um,
which I think sort of sets up the book and that she's going to tell her story
from her perspective and it really is a story of her life.
So it starts from when she's at at 10 years old and we follow her til she's
about 50.
And
I think of it as kind of a nested fairy tale where,
uh,
Agnes has her own rags to rich
arc of her life.
And then toward the last third a quarter of the book,
we get much more of a Cinderella elements and get sort of Cinderella story
embedded the longer story of the stepmothers like.
So I'll leave it at that and we can have a chat.
Yeah,
I have questions that I wanted to ask Danielle,
but then we want to open it up to the group too and,
and have a discussion and hopefully you guys all have questions for her as well.
But I'd love to start with this is your first piece of fiction with everything
before has been very factual and interesting and beautiful,
but this is fiction.
What looked you're new to this methodology of writing?
Well,
I had always wanted to be a novelist my entire life and I took a very,
very long detour through medicine and science nonfiction and sort of finally got
back to my true love.
Um,
I just,
I think that fiction is one more way in which we can examine our lives and the
world that we live in.
I think it's a,
it's a tool that can make us think differently about our everyday lives.
So true.
And how did you come up then with this particular idea of the retelling of
Cinderella from her stepmother's perspective?
So I had had a different novel in the back of my mind for a long time.
Um,
but then I became a stepmother and I spent a lot of time thinking about being a
Scott mother.
Cause it was something that I struggled with.
It's not,
you don't grow up thinking when I grow up I want to be a stepmom.
It just happens to you and you haven't usually thought it through.
And I was really surprised at how challenging our relationship that was.
And what I realized was that there are a lot of intrinsic difficulties in the
relationship because for the child,
especially if it's due to divorce,
so the child already has two loving parents welcoming another parent to their
lives is not something that they're looking to do.
You know,
they didn't want this other stranger coming into their lives and ordering them
around and changing their routines and sucking up the attention of one of their
parents.
You know,
it's sort of a net negative.
They already feel supported and loved and have everything that they need from
their biological parents.
And also for the step parents.
I realize it's also challenging because I think,
you know,
we make a lot of assumptions about human relationships and one of the
assumptions we make is that if you're an adult and you enter into a child's life
that you are automatically going to love that child and that child is
automatically going to love you back.
But it doesn't always work that way.
It takes time.
You know?
It's not like when you have your own child.
I think that nature,
mother nature gives us the gift of this is bond when your child is born,
but being a step parent is a bit like your kid bringing a friend home and then
all of a sudden you have to be a parent to that friend and then so you don't,
you don't know that child as well.
You don't necessarily have that bond already and especially if they have
resentments or anyway,
they don't see you as a net positive in their lives can be a really challenging
relationship because you have to do all this stuff for the child that you do for
your own child.
You have to cook and clean and care for them and drive them around.
But they don't necessarily,
I mean you're on kids probably don't say thank you either,
but,
um,
they don't,
you know,
they don't necessarily love you.
Like they don't,
they don't give you the hugs and kisses and all this stuff that makes it easier
to,
to do.
And so when I was thinking about that,
I thought,
Huh,
I wonder,
I was thinking that how vilified step moms are in so many fairytales.
And then I thought,
I wonder if those grew out of this intrinsically difficult relationship and that
behind these tales are just ordinary,
flawed human beings trying to get along and trying to have a relationship.
Um,
and that's where Agnes was born,
right.
Balance of describing agonises perspective from Cinderella because there were so
many roads throughout the book where you could see the commonalities between the
fairy tale and Agnes,
his version of the reality of her tail.
How did you find that right balance?
Um,
so I really wanted it to feel like a real family,
you know,
like real people who are struggling with these issues.
And so I have the most challenging thing about the book was trying to thread the
needle between making the stepmother legitimately eval because she couldn't be
this wonderful person or there'd be no story there.
Right.
So she had to actually conform to the fairytale she had to be a pretty
suboptimal parent to Cinderella.
But at the same time I wanted the reader to have developed an empathy for that
character that they could actually see how she got to this place.
Um,
and so one of the ways in which I tried to do that was I would say I was
inspired by a story that a colleague told me a long time ago.
Um,
she was telling me about how her child has obsessive compulsive disorder and her
husband does as well.
And she was saying that it's so difficult for her to parent the child relative
to her husband because she doesn't intrinsically understand,
um,
the ways in which his OCD affects how he absorbs everything around him,
about the world.
So she said,
you know,
the family goes to the zoo,
he steps in a puddle,
gets a wet sock,
and then he has to go home and change a sock.
And she'll try to talk him out of it and say,
you know,
the whole family is here,
can't we just,
you know,
go without a shoe and a sock.
And her husband will say,
oh,
what SOC is intolerable?
Of course we have to go home and change your sock because he just has a much
more visceral understanding of how the child is experiencing that wet sock that
she not having OCD herself couldn't really understand.
So this was a story she told me.
And um,
I've thought about that a lot as a parent,
how you understand some of your children more easily than others because you
have traits in common with.
Um,
and so I tried to build this relationship where,
you know,
the stepmother's not a horrible person or a good person.
Cinderella is not a horrible person or a good person,
but they have this disconnect.
They,
the way that they are in the world is very different.
And the way Cinderella has been brought up is very different from how Agnes has
been brought up.
And so she doesn't,
she really doesn't understand the girl
in the beginning of the novel,
Agnes says,
and I love this line,
compelling fiction often obscures the humble truth.
How do you think very tales and folklore influence our expectations and
experiences in the real world?
I think that,
um,
I think fairy tales are so appealing because they're really morally ambiguous.
Just like marvel movies or you know,
a lot of the stories that we absorb as children,
we know who the good guys are.
None of the bad guys are,
we know who to root for and we're going to be happy when the good guy wins.
And we really don't care when the bad guy gets blown up or has her eyes pecked
out by birds in the case of the stepsisters or because we know they're bad.
And so we don't have to waste a single moment feeling bad for them.
We can just clap your hands and say that was a great story.
Um,
I think that for children there are things that they can learn from fairy tales
about how to be generous,
how to be good,
how to be loyal and brave and so on.
So there are,
I think,
some good lessons to be learned from fairytales.
But I also think that our,
our natural tendency,
especially in the western world,
to put everything in categories,
this has been a way of thinking that has been very adaptive for Western society.
You know,
from Greek logic on,
it's given us the enlightenment,
giving us computers,
you know,
the ability to put things in category and say if this then not that,
this person is good,
this person is bad.
Sort of things that categories that are exclusive,
but those don't apply while the humans.
And I think that we have a tendency to want to use that same way of thinking,
um,
as applies to humans.
And it's very satisfying in a fairytale.
But in real life I think it really can trip us up because of course people
aren't good or bad,
you know,
he'd say I'm a good person.
Like,
well good relative to what,
like who are the bad people I'm comparing myself to.
Um,
and I think that gets us into these ways of thinking about,
you know,
people in jail.
It must be bad people because they're in jail.
And so therefore we can let us ourselves off the hook about sort of caring what
happens.
And we get into a tizzy when people we think are good people.
You know,
Comedians who made us laugh growing up who seemed like good people do terrible
things and then we don't know,
like our heads explode cause we don't know how to hold that in our head.
That wow,
this person who I had slotted in the category of good person is now having these
behaviors that are,
that are bad.
And so,
um,
in this way,
the novel really is looking at the backstory.
So what if those categories that we put people in really don't exist?
And what if they're just people,
which feels so timely right now.
Not only in teams,
we work with our families,
but our society right now in our country right now where it's so divided and
just having moments of trying to see different perspectives is challenging but
so critical.
Yeah.
It's something that really stuck with me after reading this book.
Maybe I actually do spend some time with my father talking about politics.
Maybe.
Maybe understanding and backstory is is good.
Yeah.
But the time and these categories though,
there's the aesthetic part of it too.
And Danielle and I,
when we have been talking about the book before,
it was interesting because we shared an experience of the original Cinderella
fairytale or when we read this book,
it's really so lovely and beautiful and blonde with this teeny tiny little
waist.
And Danielle and I'm,
when we were growing up were like,
well,
you know,
that's great,
but like we don't have long hair and like we don't fit that profile.
How that her figure is drawn.
So we felt really resonated more with his stepsisters.
And I'm just wondering,
what do you think that does to people long term when you don't fit the idealized
version of,
of the characters like Cinderella and you are,
you resonate with stepsisters who are seen as more evil and ugly and terrible
and all the things you don't want to be.
Yeah,
I thought about that a lot.
Writing the book and I think it's,
it's complicated.
It messed with my mind a bit when I was a kid,
right?
Cause I was this tall,
lanky,
dark haired person.
I didn't have like the blonde curls are the tiny feet.
And so when I would play games with my friends,
so we played make believe I'd always have to be one of the boys,
have to be a man,
I'd have to be the villain often.
Um,
because I was much more manly.
And so,
uh,
I longed to be that delicate little thing.
You know,
I longed to be that ideal of feminine beauty with the tiny feet and,
and so on.
But I also feel in some ways it was actually really good for me not to have
grown up feeling that I could be the Cinderella character because I think it
caused me to put all of that aside of like,
Nope,
I'm just,
I'm not going to be that pretty feminine,
a little thing.
So I may as well just ignore that.
I'll be aspirations,
the central aspiration that I think can be quite harmful for children.
You know,
this leaning in for the brass ring,
the marriage that that's going to transform you.
You're going to go through this portal and you'll be someone else coming out the
other side.
I didn't grow up with thinking any of that.
And I actually think that that turned out to be a good thing.
Um,
I also think it's really interesting because of course you can be beautiful and
not to society's expectations of what's beautiful.
And so with the step sisters,
I played with that a little bit.
So one of them is beautiful,
but because fairness,
hair,
skin fair,
which means beautiful,
also means Pale.
And that was very much the sort of fetish in the Middle Ages.
Would you be pale,
pale,
as Pale as you possibly can be.
So one of them is dark skinned and doesn't,
you know,
fit that ideal of beauty even though she's beautiful.
Um,
but then the other sister is disfigured and does not,
you know,
even her mother doesn't think she's beautiful and um,
that's a really hard thing for her and that society,
especially in a society where people,
you know,
people still believed back then,
what was it called?
Physionomy the science that says that what you look like actually tells of your
character.
So I can tell by how broad your forehead is or how small your noses,
whether you're a mean person or a smart person.
So they actually in the Middle Age ages believed this.
So it was very hard for them to not conform to that beauty.
But the city,
the sister who is disfigured,
who has no chance of anyone ever thinking she's beautiful,
it's actually very freed by that,
you know,
she doesn't give a fig what anyone thinks of her.
Like she's just been sort of released from so much of society's expectations
because she just has to put aside this idea that she could ever be that ideal of
feminine beauty,
like her,
her stepsister,
and she becomes such an interesting character.
Like she does so much that it gives her this other kind of beauty.
But she's the one who we've met for
Agnes goes through so many challenges through the book.
So much upheaval,
so much he has to fight for.
You have the title is all the ever afters where,
where is that title comes up?
So it has kind of a double meaning.
One of the meanings is that threat our life and Agnes is very typical of this.
I think that we,
there are these,
um,
it's like climbing a mountain where you have these sort of false peaks and you
think,
oh,
I just get up there,
then I'm going to be totally happy if I just get into this university.
If I just get this job that I want,
if I just get this spouse or I've only,
I could become a parent or you know,
all of these things that you think,
okay,
when I get to that place,
when I win this award,
when I get this grant and then I'm going to be happy.
And of course we get to that place and it is happy.
It's not bad,
but it's never the ever after.
You know,
then life goes on after that and it's,
you're never at the pinnacle.
And so I think of life as a series of happily ever after is Cinderella,
get married.
But her life doesn't end there.
You know,
she's happy,
she gets married to prince,
but it goes on and Agnes is life is this sort of series of events good and bad
and none of them are ever after until the very end.
Um,
the other meaning,
one of the things I find really fascinating about stories,
cause I think that we really look at life through a narrative lens is,
um,
when a story has a happy ending.
Like,
if you and I are in competing in a spelling bee and you win,
I would,
I doubt that would happen.
But okay.
But then you get your happily ever after,
right?
Like that man.
But the story includes me too.
And so your story is the happy and mine as the,
Oh,
I'm so sad,
you know,
because my dreams are crushed.
And so that's the other meaning of all the ever afters.
This is not just about one person,
you know,
it's not just about Cinderella is about Cinderella's stepmother and her dad,
her stepsisters,
you know,
it's about everybody's rafters.
So Ela is described throughout your novel is somewhat of a spoiled child,
incredibly different from the idolized Cinderella's that we all know.
Yet she's far more dimensional,
dimensional,
and realized.
How did you design that character?
So,
uh,
so getting back to,
I wanted there to be this disconnect between the stepmother and her
stepdaughter.
And I thought about what is Cinderella like from the fairy tale that we hear?
She's sweet,
she's kind,
she's very quiet,
she's obese.
She always follows the rules.
She's maybe friends with animals and the Disney version.
And actually in the Grimm brothers first version as well.
And,
um,
so I wanted to create a character where she could be like a real,
cause that doesn't sound like a real,
I mean as a parent you think,
but that's pretty one dimensional.
Again,
I can't imagine a child who's on Lido things.
Um,
but I thought that people who are not neurotypical often have some of this
traits like,
you know,
being more rule following and so on.
And I'm surrounded by people like that in Palo Alto and in my family.
And I just thought,
I just said,
you know,
like I could see that disconnect between somebody who grew up in a,
in a very rough and tumble world,
living with this girl who had many privileges,
who sort of,
hasn't learned the same life lessons,
but who also just has a very different way of seeing the world.
You know,
she's so much quieter.
She just isn't,
she doesn't have the same.
Um,
uh,
Agnes,
his daughters are very like physical and someone and she's much more like,
I think she describes her at one point like,
um,
uh,
like sun sparkling on the water.
You know,
it's just,
there's something about her that's a bit more dreamy,
that's a bit more interior.
And uh,
so I wanted to make it so that the Cinderella character wouldn't be spoiled.
Like I,
I didn't intend for to come across that way.
And I,
I think one of the things that's a real challenge is the story is told in the
first person.
So you really only get Agnes,
his view of everybody.
And so I had to show that she's feeling disconnected from this child and,
but I tried to have other characters in the story come in and show how much they
love the Cinderella character.
You know,
how much they think she's this wonderful tiles,
which she is,
she's just,
you know,
from Agnes perspective,
they just have this disconnect.
So that was what I was trying to go for with,
so that you can understand how Agnes was not the best step parents or her,
but you could also see that it's not Cinderella's vaults.
You know,
that other people adore her and think she's the best.
But I think she's also described at some point as almost a vessel for anyone
that she comes in contact with because she is maybe less three dimensional than
one might imagine that people could put their own desires of who she should be
upon her.
Yeah.
Although that was more a commentary on celebrity.
So what I was thinking of there is how we admire,
they do these gorgeous human beings in Hollywood or elsewhere or like Princess
Diana.
Um,
when I was a kid,
you know,
people got up in the middle of the night to watch the royal wedding and it was
such a big deal and we all got our hair cut like that and we all wear the little
really corny.
Sure.
Different.
So we all wanted to dress like her,
but we didn't know anything about her.
I mean she was a celebrity.
She was an unknown.
She was a blank parchment and she was that person that we all have your
belongings.
They sort of [inaudible] longings that we projected at her or at movie stars.
Um,
but it's not about who they are as people.
It's really about our own desires and our own longings.
So who I loved most in the book is our main character,
Agnes.
She's so strong.
She's so resilient.
She fights so hard for what she believes in and for the people that she loves,
she says at one point in the book to her two daughters,
every woman's serves a master via an overlord or a husband.
And she's fortunate if he does not beat her or treat her cruelly.
Everything you have I got for you,
either through marriage or hard work,
there is no alternative.
The men in his novel are often hairless and even cool while the women show
resilience and care.
Can you talk about your choice of a writer?
So I'm not sure there's such a stark line between the men and the women,
but certainly Cinderella is a story about women and women's lives.
And you know,
throughout the world and over history,
women have often been treated much more like possessions than like real people.
So I wanted to show,
even though the women lived within a very narrow sphere,
I wanted to show the full sort of richness of their lives and their,
their characters.
Um,
but I mean they're not all great people.
In fact,
some of the people who torture Agnes the most,
there's her boss,
the nurse when she,
a kid who's pretty evil and toward her.
And then,
um,
you know,
much of her disappointment comes from the Abas who she at first admire so much.
And so,
so the women are certainly not perfect characters and I think that the men are,
they are a little bit more side characters because it is a story about women.
Um,
but I think that they're also very,
very complicated.
And part of why I think we see them as a more negative is again,
because we're seeing them through Agnes as eyes and she's a very complicated
relationship with men because she lives in a society where it's impossible for
her to have a relationship of equals with a man.
It's just not set up that way and she knows it.
And she really resents the fact that they have so much more freedom that and so
many more entitlements than she has,
but at the same time she needs them to be able to survive,
to be able to get ahead and do what she wants in her life.
And so she's got this complex relationship where when she feels any sort of
tenderness toward a man,
it feels to her a little bit like weakness.
And so I don't know if maybe it was hard to pick up in the book,
but I was trying to get at,
especially with her husband when she marries Cinderella's father that he's
completely besotted with her.
Like he really loves her,
but she can't admit that to herself because it's just too complicated.
You know,
she,
she needs to like hold that at arm's length because,
and sort of stick with I need to take care of me and you take care of my kids.
Like this is,
I can't let myself get too soft.
Right?
Yeah.
When mentoring women is definitely something I think a lot of us think about and
certainly something that I think about a lot and I've benefited from and I try
to actively make time to help with.
It's definitely a theme in the book,
both in really beautiful and powerful positive ways,
but also in hurtful,
tragic ways.
Can you talk about that and a little bit?
Sure.
Um,
so,
uh,
so Cinderella,
Cinderella,
Agnes,
the stepmother is a barn,
a peasant.
And so she of course is completely,
she had no access to education.
Um,
but she,
she wants to read when she's a servant,
when this elderly,
very wealthy,
very powerful countess who maybe it's somewhat eccentric for the times.
She,
she believes in girls potential and so she teaches her to read.
Um,
and it's not a coincidence that the daughter of this countess is the very
powerful Abas who is the fairy godmother,
not magical,
just that she's the godmother figure in the story.
And young Agnes when she's a teenager has,
uh,
she's really drawn to this very smart and charismatic woman who is one of the
most powerful people in a very religious country at the time.
And so she wants to follow her,
like her heart just goes to this woman and,
um,
she decides that she wants to join the church and to sort of follow in her
footsteps.
Um,
but what she can't see,
I mean,
there's,
there's a class division,
so she doesn't quite understand the way in which being of such low birth means
there was never any chance at this.
But also I wanted for the Abas to be a character who has achieved great things,
but then kind of pulled up the ladder after herself.
You know,
when I was,
um,
when I was in medical school back in the early nineties,
there were some of the women doctors I really admired,
especially in the fields that were very male dominated at the time,
like surgery and cardiology,
who were really neat.
Um,
and at the time we,
we've said of the my fellow female students than I,
that if they had to be that way in order to make it in such a tough field at
such a tough time,
like if they hadn't had that sort of personality or that like rough exterior
that they would not have been able to make it.
And I think that the Abas is one of those sorts of people.
But as I've gotten older,
I've also felt like,
oh,
it a little bit to the women who came behind them not to pull up the ladder
quite so hard behind them.
And I,
I wondered how much being a powerful woman in a male dominated world makes you
feel even better about yourself than if there were a lot of other successful
women.
Because maybe that makes you even more special,
that you're the only one,
you know,
you're the only one who could make it.
So that's,
that's character.
She fulfills a bit of that.
That's where that role
and it's so true too.
There is really a truth in that.
Um,
I want to open this up to folks here have,
have questions for,
and Danielle,
I didn't want to dominate her completely,
although I have plenty more to ask her.
But um,
yes,
sure.
So I started,
um,
working on this book when I was still working full time as a physician,
but then I later quit and the hemo full time writer.
So at first I was mostly working on airplanes flying back and forth across the
country because I was working in Boston and living in California if it is kind
of nuts.
And so I read a lot of books about the middle ages to try to get some of those
details right.
Um,
and then when I started writing full time,
uh,
I really tried to it like a job,
just like when I had to go into my workplace.
So I have the luxury of being able to start later in the morning.
I get to go exercise first thing in the morning and I don't have to,
nobody's paying attention to when I actually get onto my computer.
But I really try to sort of set aside those hours from sort of mid morning until
time to start making dinner and just,
and just work through.
And it's not,
at least for me,
it's not possible to be productive and creative through that entire period.
But I,
I try when I'm feel like I'm running out of steam,
I try to spend time doing other things like research for other projects or for
that project or sort of like reading and background,
um,
other ways to,
so that it's still part of my,
my work day.
Cause I think it's really easy as a writer to just procrastinate and for things
to go year after year without getting done.
So the book was set in a medieval setting.
So you did quite a bit of research.
I'm imagining for this book.
I know you've visited castle hearing about some of your trips.
Can you talk a little bit about that part of the process?
Yeah,
so mostly I,
I read books in the beginning just about what medieval villages where,
like with medieval castle for like that sort of thing to get a sense of,
of the life.
But a lot of it was on Google and youtube.
It's amazing how much you can find out.
You know,
there are people who are hobbyists who brew beer in a medieval style.
You can actually go on youtube and watch somebody making medieval beer.
And so I learned so much by people who've done this research for their own
amusement.
Um,
so that,
yeah,
so that was a big part of it.
And you know,
one of the things I discovered when I was doing the research is that there's not
much known about the poor people from the Middle Ages.
So the rich people who could read and write,
we have a fairly good records at least of who married who,
and then the kid was home and all that sort of stuff.
But,
um,
for the illiterate poor,
nobody was writing anything about them.
And so we actually know very little what we do know is mostly from having exempt
bones from graveyards and looking at what ages children died and trying to
figure out what children died from.
And um,
the,
the few tax records that existed at the time.
Tell us a little bit about the,
the villages and so on,
like you know,
who had to pay taxes on how many oxygen.
Um,
and that's kind of it,
which actually it was very comforting to me because I was really worried about
getting historical details wrong and then I realized,
well even the historians are arguing about what actually happened.
So I felt a little more laxed after that.
Do other folks have have questions for Danielle?
I have one I was wondering about in thinking about this discussion,
so you have children and stepchildren.
If they were to write a book
with you included,
what do you think the title would be of my book about me written from your
children?
It would be
what's for dinner?
I'm serious.
I mean that's how kids are,
right?
Like they don't really see their parents as people.
Oh,
there it is.
Like,
this is,
the story would go like this.
There's this nice,
once upon a time there was this nice lady,
she cooked really good food.
I love her.
Okay.
That's kind of,
I think that's,
it should be,
you know.
Okay.
They've got their own stuff going on.
So what are you working on now?
Okay,
so right now I'm working on then,
you know,
I mentioned I had this mobile in the back of my mind for 10 years.
Well,
so I finally got around to,
I'm writing that.
MMM.
So it's not historical fiction.
That's actually,
is that in 2003 which isn't that historical and it takes place in Canada,
in Toronto during,
there was a big blackout in the northeast of the United States and a big chunk
of Canada in August of 2003.
And,
um,
the inspiration for the story was the poem,
the love Song of jail for Prufrock by Tsl yet,
which is one of my very favorite poems.
Okay.
MMM.
And if you're not familiar with it,
it's,
uh,
it's narrated by a character who is approaching or in middle age.
Okay.
Who has a big okay decision.
A challenging decision to make.
Yeah.
It sounds like it's a of a romantic nature that we never find out what exactly
what this choices.
Yeah.
Okay.
But what's so tragic about the poem is that he knows even before he made the
choice did he doesn't have the guts to do it.
Yeah.
And the reason is that he lives in such a comfortable life.
He's got this very upper middle class comfortable life.
Like I have measured out my days with coffee spoons,
you know,
the women come and go.
Speaking of Michelangelo,
all this lines that talk about the sprinklers on the streets and just,
it's just this beautiful comfortable life and he just cannot smash that all to
bits to do this.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Which is,
he might have,
yeah.
The courage to do.
And so in my story,
the,
um,
the prefect character is a woman in her sixties who's planning the birthday
party of her mother.
And Ah,
there's the other main character is her daughter in law and we sort of watch
their parallel lives even though they're 25,
30 years apart in age.
Um,
they have very similar trajectories of their lives and they come together at a
certain point and then they take berry different paths.
So the older woman is the one who didn't have the courage to take a chance.
And the younger woman,
um,
sort of smashes everything apart by she yeah.
Leaves her husband for a woman she's falling in love with at work and just,
you know,
right.
Creates havoc.
And it sort of follows both of them through the blackout where they each have
their sort of separate epiphany's about their choices and okay.
No,
yeah.
Done in the world.
And the reason I chose to set it during the blackout is that my brothers were
both living in Toronto at the time.
And they told me about how it was when all the lights went out,
that people actually came out of their houses and onto their stoops and they
talk to their neighbors and people had barbecues,
they had block parties basically because that was the only way you can eat with,
okay.
Grill your food.
And so I think in a black hat can go different,
have very different ways.
I mean,
there could have been rioting and looting and it could have been horrible,
but it turned out that it was,
people volunteered to go direct traffic.
It was just this very,
it really brought the city together.
And so I think for the jail,
for Prufrock characters,
she has lived her life in fear and then she sees that humanity does have this
goodness.
And I think that that really sort of causes her to realize that maybe the fierce
has been living under business place.
Oh,
sounds so good.
When is it going to come out?
I'm going to get it done.
We'll look forward to that.
So unless,
unless folks have have other thoughts or questions.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
uh,
yes.
I can repeat the question for you.
MMM.
If you were to write about another fairy tale and take on a different
perspective,
what would that be?
Okay,
yeah.
Yeah.
So that's a really great question.
Um,
I have thought about it.
I haven't thought,
I haven't come up with a great answer.
One of my favorite fairy tales is a beauty and the beast.
I really liked that bell has a little more agency than Cinderella.
You know,
she's,
she,
and she's really making choices for other people in her life.
MMM.
So I liked that fairytale.
Yeah.
Yes.
The twist I haven't really come up with,
I really like that the,
um,
so the original fairytale,
some people think is based MMM.
A man who had,
um,
hypertrichosis so he had this very rare genetic disease where he was basically
covered in hair.
People with this condition,
they can grow hair all over their bodies.
And so he,
his face was all covered my hair and he married this beautiful woman.
MMM.
He was upperclass in France and married a beautiful woman.
And so I love that story because,
okay.
What I don't like about beauty and the beast is that he turns into,
uh,
prints.
Literally,
he has to turn into this vein for her to like really be like,
okay,
now I'll marry you.
But I really liked the idea that he becomes beautiful in her eyes because she
falls in love with him.
So I've been playing with that.
I haven't quite come up with the right sort of take on it,
but I,
if I were to do a twist,
it would be that he doesn't turn beautiful.
She just sees him as beautiful because she loves him so much.
Yeah,
you should write that one too.
All right.
Well thank you so much and thanks everybody for joining us.
Thanks.